welcome to this video playing to 20 min
20 min Israel yeah I went for a modern
defense let's see is going from quick
punishment with f4 okay I'm trying to do
something offbeat yeah isn't this it's
this okay for black or not maybe I can
play with is 65 something like that okay
d5 yes that's not that bad I guess
getting the bishop out and then putting
it on light squares here huh Queen to d3
isn't this quite okay now I don't know
Queen takes would be funny Bishop f5 and
white resigns
I'm not my development is this a problem
maybe I should try to get get the Queen
out here to prepare long castles see for
Queen a5 should be alright I guess okay
yeah 205 mm yeah again there is there is
something like Bishop f5 sometimes
that's not a bad position I can
castlelong I can take my eggs
yeah I can I can play that oh that's not
bad you have some pressure against the
center Knight f5 Knight d5 our moves
no maybe you should just go see 3m cover
his pawn and just reroute the knight via
a 3 c2 something like that yeah c3 looks
looks ok so he's just giving me the pawn
on what is the exact point just winning
d4 now right
take c @ xt form maybe with the bishop
yong-joo to get us get rid of his bishop
pair immediately he has really has no
way to go i have it should be one Bishop
III so he takes Knight takes and yeah
that's very nice for black yeah just a
pawn Knight c3 was a weird decision
really I think he could have played c3
without any any big big issue okay so
who takes yeah why not you take and now
this move activating and Bishop g4 runs
into 93 which is yeah this runs into
this yeah I really don't know what does
he doing now mhm 5 or f5 this but I can
just take g2
no reason not to and F voice immediately
hanging with the tempo again so maybe
here I don't know
it all looks nice night might come to e5
here
maybe just I know if six is stupid right
yeah okay let's get centralized and go
from here I can do here now again
I know I can take situ
rooks it to rook to e3 yeah
with the pants are dropping like flies
here it's three now
check three pawns and I have a perfect
structure check
hmm okay yeah he's continuing this with
unfolded enthusiasm check checked really
no giant because it's really very little
hope him check check
well rook endings are very often drawn
or Jewish but for pawns
it's not like there's a ton of stalemate
tricks here check
no that is a statement that said that's
actually a nice trick because of the
pre-move idea nice okay I can go here
white reserved
yeah that's its that's cute Dupree okay
so the I think one one issue was that
when we and we go back here yeah I
already cannot say something about the
opening I was just playing like
freestyle chess do do think about stuff
on my own here yeah I really think c3
should be good yeah
stabilizing his Center and I mean I
really think I'm okay you have no bad
piece and so on but there's nothing
nothing happening really something like
this yeah light will come back into play
as it's probably about equal but after
that I'm really just winning material
yeah and somehow I went to win when even
more those nights were really pesky in
our four pawns yeah and three yeah at
four points no three three points but
somehow yeah whatever he could have
resigned here with the clear conscience
okay
thanks for watching